I almost run into your box but America
don't play like that baby hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to slit burial I've been
trying for a while now to get good and
unfortunately my skills of getting and
good are non-existent pretty much for
the most part but now that I've started
recording I have a funny feeling I'm
gonna do much better than I have been
doing and how I have been doing has been
well we're not gonna talk about how I
have been doing because I have been
doing terribly but from now on i oh god
damn it I'm just a sack of crap I know I
am I know I am now we can finally see
the stars and stripe in their full glory
as they were always meant to be so
anyway um as far as getting good at so
there you know the answer is no I have
not hundreds and no um but changes have
been made to the game to make it a
little more fair and overall from
everything else that has been done
before there's been many many many
changes
well not that many we're getting
somewhere not not a lot of places but
America don't play America don't play
America believes in freedom an America
shall deliver right give me your freedom
give me all your freedom oh [ __ ] Oh God
okay Oh Gershwin Oh George Gershwin Oh
stars it's a forever legitimate him you
guys saw that
I got robbed now that America's getting
back to a respectable length as America
hopefully we'll be able to establish our
dominance here just like everywhere else
in everything that we establish
dominance in you know childhood obesity
childhood diabetes we're never wanted
all those categories and no one who ever
stopped was ever never forever as we are
America America is not afraid to run
away from a fright
it takes a lot of bravery to be that
brave right now America's just scooping
up the scraps from everybody else's
battles but soon America will stand on
America's own and of course America
refers to America in the America person
not the third person we're not some
third world country where the world I
was about to say worst but that's not
what America is everybody watching out
merican coming through or about yourself
worried about America Wow wow that could
have got me if he'd have been a little
more conscious about where he was joltin
Jesus Oh God yeah yeah what America
kills America keeps even though I was
just about to run away screaming that
don't matter to you just let me be me
and everything will be fine I'm number
two on leaderboard marker for America oh
I just gotta hold on to it desperately
and never let go
just like everything else [ __ ] [ __ ]
wants a piece of America the population
is getting a little dense over there I
don't know why but everyone was
congregating in one spot and no one
seems to be dying I don't know I got a
bad feeling about this
oh hello it's me apparently I don't know
why but it's me everyone's just calling
in a bunch of circles no one seems to be
exploring anywhere are these actual
players are they just like computers
that are programmed to go in like
circles that's bizarre oh my god that
would have been embarrassing
damn it like I'm stuck on number two and
it seems it seems like there might be
some sweer behavior going whoo hey zap
how you doing oh man oh man oh there we
go
yeah it's delicious dad's dust stuff did
I was looking for wool hey what are you
doing there
that's gonna carry on goodbye everybody
see ya ah [ __ ] I'm slightly behind
number one number one this is too much
to ask for probably probably a lot man
everybody's like in perpetual oh no
bueno oh [ __ ] the lag so scared for leg
ok leg jeez lag is gonna give me what
I'm so close I'm so close to victory yes
yeah glorious moment oh this may not be
able to top of a server to go on but
whoa for one
glorious moment I am the victor oh my
god I did it I did it I did the server
that's probably filled with all kinds of
BOTS I have no idea though oh [ __ ]
alright we're fine everything's fine
okay well thank you for sacrificing
yourself to the great cause that is the
Marquis mu nu the Marga fart appreciates
your can-do do not worry your body will
be imbibed by the great country America
and will be put to the best of use
possible well now that I'm number one
what else can I do I mean I always knew
that I was number one in my heart of
hearts but now I have so much potential
that guy was that guy was for realsies
the doom spiral has begun again the
cycle begins anew the death will come as
eventually soon just piles of turds
don't mind us just trying to scoop a
little bit of victory there we go that's
sweet yes I almost got me the mercury
yeah maybe I should just go into the
corner and hide there and just keep my
title forever and ever in perpetuity
hey chica how's it going I'm a winner
chica chickens between my legs I'm a
winner chica look at me I know you think
I'm a loser but it's okay I proved you
wrong whatever I was number one and I
was number one for a while so I did it
yeah
number one okay so thank you everybody
so much for watching I think in the next
if I do another one of these I'm gonna
play with you guys again and then try to
get a big party going on then get number
one with you guys even though you guys
are trying to sabotage me why so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
much more intensely than they planned